-Our next guest is the host of
"Mike Vecchione Investigates,"
available at Apple Podcasts.
Please welcome
one of our favorites back
to "The Tonight Show" stage,
the very funny Mike Vecchione!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much, everybody.
It's great to be here.
First, I would like to thank
Mr. Jimmy Fallon for bringing
live stand-up comedy back
to television.
Amazing.
And shout-out to New York City.
We're coming back, baby.
We're gonna make it.
There are some things
I'm going to miss about
the pandemic, though.
For example,
walking into a restaurant
and having my temperature taken
like I'm being executed.
I enjoy it.
"This is to make you feel safe!"
I like it when
the hostess takes a break
and I go up
and take the thermometer
and I just start using it
on people for comedy reasons.
A couple walks in.
You know,
I point it to the woman
and I go, "You're pregnant.
You're pregnant."
Then I point it to the guy and
go, "You're not the father."
I've been going to the gym.
And there's a lot of
paperwork at the gym now.
I go there.
The guy gives me like 10 forms.
I go, "Yeah, I'm not trying to
purchase the gym.
I'm just trying to get
a workout."
He goes, "We're trying to
determine whether you're
healthy enough
to be at the gym."
I'm like, "Hey, buddy,
let me save you some trouble.
I'm not healthy enough
to be at the gym.
If I was healthy enough
to be at the gym,
I wouldn't be at the gym, okay?
I'd be at home
eating doughnuts."
I try to keep up
with my mental health.
I'm doing affirmations.
And the affirmation I do is
"Millionaire Mindset."
Every morning, I sit on
the couch, I close my eyes,
and I repeat the phrase, "I am a
very powerful millionaire.
I am a very powerful
millionaire.
Hey, guys, I'm a very powerful
millionaire."
Girlfriend walks out, shakes me,
interrupts my mind-set,
you know?
And she goes, "You left the
dishes in the sink last night.
Is that what we're doing?
Leaving the dishes in the sink?"
I turn to her.
I'm like, "Do you know who
you're talking to?
I am a very powerful
millionaire.
You can't talk to a very
powerful millionaire that way."
But later, I found out she
had been doing
"A Billionaire Mindset."
But arguments
can escalate in quarantine.
They really can.
For example,
my girlfriend is from Indiana.
And did you guys know
that people from Indiana
do not like to be called
hillbillies?
Yeah. That is a slur.
The politically correct term is
"farm-to-table."
The farm-to-tables don't like it
when you call them hillbillies.
It gets their overalls
in a twist.
So, the argument --
it's escalating.
She goes,
"You're always mad at me.
That's the problem."
I go,
"I don't think that's true."
She goes, "It is,
and to prove it,
I'm going to start a log.
Every time you get mad at me,
I'm going to
write it down in the log."
I was like,
"Look, no disrespect,
but you have a tendency
to overreact sometimes,
so I would like access
to the log."
She goes, "No, you will not have
access to the log."
I go, "Well, then I'm gonna
start my own log.
Every time you deny me
access to your log,
I'm gonna write it down
in my log."
And that was
the last argument we had.
We don't argue anymore
because it's too much paperwork.
I figure if I want to do
that much paperwork,
I'd go to the gym.
I'm a Catholic, and I've been
praying for you guys.
You're welcome.
When you're Catholic, what you
do is, you go to church.
It's open now. It's legal.
You say a prayer.
You light a candle.
But I'm a
very competitive Catholic.
So before I light my candle,
I blow everybody else's
candle out.
I've been losing massive amounts
of weight in the quarantine
because I've been doing
intermittent fasting.
And the philosophy behind
intermittent fasting
is that you're not supposed to
eat all the time.
Sometimes,
you're not supposed to eat.
And I was doing it as a child
because my father
had a gambling problem.
He would lose the money that we
were gonna use to buy food --
he would lose it on football.
And my friends were no help.
They're like, "Mike, are you
going to eat this week?"
I was like, "I don't know.
Did the Dolphins win by 3?"
That's all my time.
You guys are amazing.
Thank you so much.
New York City, baby!
♪♪
-Mike Vecchione, thank you
for being here in the studio!
Mike Vecchione!
Check out "Mike Vecchione --
You can't see,
but you're getting
a standing ovation
from those
10 people right there.
We love you, buddy.
Thank you for doing that.
Check out
"Mike Vecchione Investigates"
at Apple Podcasts.